[Musica]
[Applauso]
Lei si chiama selai
se l'hai vedete ha gli occhi bassi
sembra un animale in gabbia è feroce
se l'hai non se la sta passando molto
bene
è stata data in sposa
da un amico di suo papà ma lei non lo
voleva
ce l'hai a 19 anni e viene da Kabul
poi c'è un cambiamento una sua amica la
convince a coltivare dello zafferano Ma
sì vai nei campi stai Un po' insieme a
noi intanto vai via da quel da quella
bestia di tuo marito e forse ti guadagna
anche due soldi
l'abbiamo rivista poco tempo dopo se
l'hai sorrideva aveva questa luce negli
occhi era Risorta praticamente risolta e
poi e poi è successa una cosa una cosa
una cosa brutta
il 15 agosto del 2021
entrano i talebani prendono possesso
dell'Afghanistan
sono paesi lontani in quei paesi lontani
non si parla mica di ospitalità di
accoglienza di amore Già mai
ma è per noi cos'è per noi cosa è per me
che mi occupo di ospitalità cos'è
l'ospitalità Oh certo può essere la
versione
industrializzata di un atto
profondamente umano quando il turismo ha
un solo scopo quello del profitto
essere albergatore però
esiste un'altra cosa
esige l'accoglienza
accogliere significa aprire non chiudere
[Applauso]
Qui si sono combattute delle guerre
atroci In quegli anni lì
nelle Dolomiti c'era la Prima Guerra
Mondiale che passava proprio proprio lì
il fronte Era proprio lì Ah e poi certo
Anche no quando parlò dei suoi viaggi
voleva
acculturarsi le vide le Dolomiti poi sì
passo a Firenze Roma Napoli
nelle Dolomiti le Dolomiti Adesso hanno
un forte appeal sono diventate Dolomiti
UNESCO UNESCO Ci siamo messi la patacca
sulla spalla mai sbaglio politico fu
stato più grande
Mica è aumentata la sensibilità degli
esseri umani che qui vivono e il tuo
quello che una volta era il gran tour di
Greta adesso è diventato un folle Turi
attraverso Anzi intorno al gruppo da
sella su e giù per i passi dolomitici
Ma la montagna Sì già rispetto
l'inquinamento acustico non può arrivare
in cima all'Adamello o in cima al Piz
Boè
e la vacanza così diventata pensate che
negli anni 70 80 gli ospiti venivano da
noi per vacare per non fare nulla beh lo
facevano anche già i romani No oziavano
adesso è diventata una cosa un po'
diversa Adesso gli ospiti devono
riempirsi di cose devono fare super mega
mille attività dallo yoga la ginnastica
la passeggiata i giochi per bambini e
2000 metri Insomma abbiamo tante cose da
fare in continuazione ieri si stava al
banco e si parlava con il barchiper Sì
sì così si dava anche via dei dialoghi
socratici No si stava insieme ci si
nutriva della conoscenza dell'altro
pensate che qualche mese fa ho parlato
con il signor Muller il signor Muller è
un appassionato sciatore e da noi ha
fatto i passi dolomitici
Anzi più di forse li ha fatti anche due
volte perché mi ha fatto vedere sul suo
aggeggio sul suo telefonino che ha fatto
126 km velocità massima 88 km/h È una
performance l'industria sciistica
richiede performance più Vai veloce più
devi più velocemente devi scendere Mamma
mia che scorrendo
ma che spavento che si industria
sciistica tutto uguale quindi le piste
tutte piatti Ah certo lo richiedono i
turisti Ah sì va bene va bene Ma pensate
d'estate ancora peggio quando con le
Ducati girano intorno al Sella
folle umanità Sono esseri
psicologicamente con delle difficoltà ma
io non sono mica un medico mio fratello
Mattia Se io non siamo mica medici siamo
solo albergatori Ma questi sono dei dei
folli eppure non va spremuto il cliente
affinché diventi ospite deve essere
coinvolto nella nel nostro mondo
dell'ospitalità deve far parte di noi
perché io non ci credo un commercio di
persone Io non credo solo ai numeri e io
non credo solo alle stelle degli
alberghi pensate che qualche anno fa
abbiamo chiesto di diventare un 5 stelle
sono venuti dalla provincia di Bolzano
dove siamo molto efficienti e con i
laser hanno misurato la metratura delle
camere
e poi hanno chiesto quanti ascensori
abbiamo Ecco ci hanno dato le cinque
stelle Fantastico No ma io le stelle le
vorrei secondo la gentilezza la qualità
la creatività la bellezza Insomma Dalle
stelle alle stalle
alle tue robustale perché sapete che in
provincia di Bolzano un litro di latte
viene pagato al contadino 527 in
provincia di Trento ancora meno sono
delle Turbo mucche e poi sono le mucche
quelle che fanno carne carne da macello
della fatica della montagna al metaverso
dall'accoglienza dall'accoglienza
dall'accogliere l'altro
[Applauso]
[Musica]
il passo è breve Eh se non ci mettiamo
il contatto con il luogo se non ci
mettiamo l'esperienza umana se non
pensiamo ripensiamo a un Rinascimento
umano
visto che di questo ci occupiamo perché
noi facciamo accoglienza ed è la cosa
più bella del mondo e invece no tutta
strategia strategie di marketing solo
marketing sono comunicazione Oddio ci
sono anche altre strategie che sono
anche un po' peggiore della nostra
[Applauso]
la peggiore carestia degli ultimi 40
anni
c'è una violazione dei diritti
delle donne e dei bambini
cosa c'entra Noi stiamo violando la
natura stiamo consumando suolo in
continuazione
una speculazione imperante fa in modo
che venga a mancarci il senso di
appartenenza pensate Io vivo lì uno dei
posti più belli del mondo
eppure c'è un consumo senza
autocoscienza sono una persona
estremamente fortunata e privilegiata
perché io posso fare quello che più mi
piace nella vita stare insieme alle
persone
fare l'albergatore
non è sempre
così come io mi immaginerei che fosse ma
d'altronde non gestiamo un convento e
non sono un monaco però soffro
soffro anch'io
soffro quando questa cucina
viene chiamata Brigata
Le brigate fanno altro nella vita
il turismo è una cosa intima e il
turista Guardate non vuole essere Sì non
può secca puntato in mezzo ai turisti
vuole sentirsi parte di noi della nostra
comunità Ecco perché dico che ci vuole
più umanità più qualità che non è data
dalle 5 piscine o della spada di 5000
metri non è questo e quindi siccome non
ci riusciamo io soffro io soffro perché
anch'io anche noi anche la mia famiglia
anche noi consumavamo suolo io soffro
perché le donne guadagnano troppo poco
io soffro perché abbiamo ospiti che
arrivano in aereo
oltreoceano c'è anche chi viene con
l'ero privato e io soffro perché per la
richiesta di un cappuccino che è stata
fatta all'altro giorno da noi in sala a
colazione c'ero lì io e ho visto Ramona
che ha messo un cappuccino nella
borraccia di un americano
Ma non soffro perché la chiesta
l'americano perché ignora la qualità del
cappuccino soffro perché noi quel
cappuccino glielo abbiamo fatto
e io soffro perché non tutti i nostri
collaboratori hanno una stanza singola e
soffro perché nel mio comune
1200 abitanti 5.000 letti non abbiamo
accolto una famiglia di profughi non
abbiamo trovato i letti
il male comune può essere
trasformato in un'economia del bene
comune e noi stilliamo periodicamente il
bilancio dell'Economia e del bene comune
ci diamo dei punteggi guardiamo e
proviamo e proviamo a capire quanto
siamo bravi perché noi non vogliamo il
frammentazione
i Foresti che girano ma vogliamo appunto
la cultura dell'ospitalità Questi sono i
nostri ragazzi che si abbracciano perché
la cosa più preziosa che abbiamo i
nostri collaboratori ne abbiamo 180
ed è una cosa meravigliosa stare in
mezzo a questi la strategia di marketing
va fatta comunque in direzione
collaboratori non più ospiti quelli
arrivano in automatico Se siamo bravi
abbastanza E questa è la missione di
casa chiariamo benessere consapevolezza
consapevolmente dando valore alla
persona perché occuparsi dell'altro È un
piacere perché è un piacere stare con la
governante di casa spomenta e con
programma
perché un piacere avere a che fare con
collaboratori che proviamo a educare
perché le loro mamme non glierano
insegnato che il coltello non va in
bocca che i gomiti non vanno sul tavolo
e che un uomo non va a cena con i
calzini corti e una donna dal bagno non
esce mai con il clip in plastica in
testa e non si dice neanche Buon
appetito Ma sono cose che sanno Ma
sapete che i nostri ragazzi non lo sono
mica tutti e quindi proviamo a
farli sorridere a stare insieme
le persone fantastiche
e stiamo insieme anche con la nostra
fondazione di famiglia
perché quella quello Zafferano che avete
visto all'inizio non possiamo più
coltivarlo
vi ricordate
nella quale vi ho portato all'inizio
di selai non abbiamo più notizie
Grazie
[Applauso]